in this talk I'm going to give you the
single most important lesson my
colleagues and I have learned from
looking at 83,000 brain scans but first
let me put the lesson into context I am
in the middle of seven children growing
up my father called me a maverick which
to him was not a good thing
in 1972 the army called my number and I
was trained as an infantry medic where
my love of medicine was born but since I
truly hated the idea of being shot at
we're sleeping in the mud I got myself
retrained as an x-ray technician and
developed a passion for medical imaging
as our professors used to say how do you
know unless you look in 1979 when I was
the second-year medical student
someone in my family became seriously
suicidal and I took her to see a
wonderful psychiatrist over time I
realized that if he helped her which he
did it would not only save her life but
it would also help her children and even
her future grandchildren as they would
be shaped by someone who is happier and
more stable I fell in love with
psychiatry because I realized it had the
potential to change generations of
people in 1991 I went to my first
lecture on brain SPECT imaging Spector's
a nuclear medicine study that looks at
blood flow and activity it looks at how
your brain works SPECT was presented as
a tool to help psychiatrists get more
information to help their patients in
that one lecture my two professional
loves
medical imaging and psychiatry came
together and quite honestly
revolutionized my life over the next 22
years my colleagues and I would build
the world's largest database of brain
scans related to behavior on patients
from 93 countries SPECT basically tells
us three things about the brain good
activity too little or too much here is
a set of healthy SPECT scans the image
on the Left shows the outside surface of
the brain and a healthy scan shows full
even symmetrical activity the color is
not important it's the shape that
matters in the image on the right red
equals the areas of high activity and in
a healthy brain they're typically in the
back part of the brain here is a healthy
scan compared to someone who had two
strokes you can see the holes of
activity here's what Alzheimers looks
like where the back half of the brain is
deteriorating did you know that
Alzheimer's disease actually starts in
the brain 30 to 50 years before you have
any symptoms here's a scan of traumatic
brain injury your brain is soft and your
skull is really hard or drug abuse the
real reason not to use drugs take damage
your brain obsessive compulsive disorder
where the front part of the brain
typically works too hard so that people
cannot turn off their thoughts an
epilepsy where we frequently see areas
of increased activity in 1992 I went to
an all-day conference on brain SPECT
imaging it was amazing and mirrored our
own early experience using SPECT in
psychiatry but at that same meeting
researchers started to complain loudly
that clinical psychiatrists like me
should not be doing scan
that they were only for their research
being a maverick and having clinical
experience I thought that was a really
dumb idea
without imaging psychiatrist then and
even now make diagnoses like they did in
1840 when Abraham Lincoln was depressed
by talking to people and looking for
symptom clusters imaging was showing us
there was a better way did you know that
psychiatrists are the only medical
specialists that virtually never look at
the organ they treat think about it
cardiologists look neurologists look
orthopedic doctors look virtually every
other Medical Specialties look
psychiatrist guess before imaging I
always felt like I was throwing darts in
the dark at my patients and had hurt
some of them which horrified me there is
a reason that most psychiatric
medications have black box warnings give
them to the wrong person and you can
precipitate a disaster early on our
imaging work taught us many important
lessons such as illnesses like ADHD
anxiety depression and addictions are
not single or simple disorders in the
brain they all have multiple types for
example here are two patients who have
been diagnosed with major depression
that had virtually the same symptoms yet
radically different brains one had
really low activity in the brain the
other one had really high activity how
would you ever know what to do for them
unless you actually looked treatment
needs to be tailored to individual
brains not clusters of symptoms are
work also taught us that mild traumatic
brain injury was a major cause of
psychiatric illness that ruined people's
lives and virtually no one knew about it
because they would see psychiatrists for
things like temper problems anxiety
depression and insomnia and they would
never look so they would never know
here's the scan of a 15 year old boy who
fell down a flight of stairs at the age
of three and even though he was
unconscious for only a few minutes there
was nothing mild about the enduring
effect that injury had on this boy's
life when I met him at the age of 15 he
had just been kicked out of his third
residential treatment program for
violence he needed a brain
rehabilitation program not just more
medication thrown at him in the dark
or behavior therapy which if you think
about it is really cruel to put him on a
behavior therapy program when behavior
is really an expression of the problem
it's not the problem researchers have
found that undiagnosed brain injuries
are a major cause of homelessness drug
and alcohol abuse depression panic
attacks ADHD and suicide we are in for a
pending disaster with the hundreds of
thousands of soldiers coming back from
Iraq and Afghanistan and virtually no
one is looking at the function of their
brain as we continued our work with
SPECT the criticism grew louder but so
did the lessons judges and defense
attorneys sought our help to understand
criminal behavior today we have scanned
over 500 convicted felons including 90
murderers our work taught us that people
who do bad things often have troubled
brags that was not a surprise
but what did surprise us was that many
of these brains could be rehabilitated
so here's a radical idea what if we
evaluated entreated troubled brains
rather than simply warehousing them in
toxic stressful environments in my
experience we could truth we could save
tremendous amounts of money by making
these people more functional so when
they left prison they could work support
their families and pay taxes
Dostoevsky once said a society should be
judged not by how well it treats its
outstanding citizens but by how it
treats its criminals instead of just
crime and punishment we should be
thinking about crime evaluation and
treatment
so after 22 years and 83,000 scans the
single most important lesson my
colleagues and I have learned is that
you can literally change people's brains
and when you do you change their life
you are not stuck with the brain you
have you can make it better and we can
prove it
my colleagues and I performed the first
and largest study on active and retired
NFL players showing high levels of
damage in these players at a time when
the NFL said they didn't know if playing
football cause long-term brain damage
the fact was they didn't want to know
that was not a surprise I think if you
get most thoughtful 9 year olds together
and you talk about the brain is soft
about the consistency of soft butter
it's housed in a really hard skull that
has many sharp bony ridges
you know 28 out of 30 9 year olds would
go probably a bad idea for your life but
what really got us excited was the
second part of the study where we put
players on a brain smart program and
demonstrated that 80% of them could
improve in the areas of blood flow
memory and mood that you are not stuck
with the brain you have you can make it
better on a brain smart program how
exciting is that I am so excited
reversing brain damage is a very
exciting new frontier but the
implications are really much wider here
is the scan of a teenage girl who has
ADHD who is cutting herself failing in
school and fighting with her parents
when we improved her brain she went from
D's and F's to A's and B's and was much
more emotionally stable here's a scan of
Nancy Nancy had been diagnosed with
dementia and her doctor told her husband
that he should find a home
for her because within a year she would
not know his name but on an intensive
brain rehabilitation program
Nancy's brain was better as was her
memory and four years later Nancy still
knows her husband's name or my favorite
story to illustrate this point is Andrew
a nine-year-old boy who attacked a
little girl on the baseball field
for no particular reason and at the time
was drawing pictures of himself hanging
from a tree and shooting other children
Andrew was Columbine Aurora and Sandy
Hook waiting to happen most
psychiatrists would have medicated
Andrew as they did Eric Harris and the
other mass shooters before they
committed their awful crimes but SPECT
imaging taught me that I had to look at
his brain and not throw darts in the
dark at him to understand what he needed
his SPECT scan showed a cyst the size of
a golf ball occupying the space of his
left temporal lobe no amount of
medication or therapy would have helped
Andrew when the cyst was removed his
behavior completely went back to normal
and he became the sweet loving boy he
always wanted to be now 18 years later
Andrew who is my nephew owns his own
home is employed and pays taxes
because someone bothered to look at his
brain he has been a better son and will
be a better husband father and
grandfather when you have the privilege
of changing someone's brain you not only
change his or her life you have the
opportunity to change generations to
come
I'm dr. Daniel Eamon